[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
MIHAI IONESCU: Hello.
Welcome to Payments Live.
We have another very exciting
session today.
We'll be talking about one of
fastest-growing growing
segments in online payments,
that is,
digital goods and services.
And our special guest today is
Google Wallet product manager
Arundhati Singh.
Arundhati, thanks for finding
the time to join us.
ARUNDHATI SINGH:
Oh, absolutely.
Very happy to be here.
Thanks, Mihai.
MIHAI IONESCU: Thank you.
We're glad to have you.
And so let's get started.
Arundhati, what is Google Wallet
for Digital Goods?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Google Wallet
for Digital Goods is a great
new service that we have to
monetize your online content
and services.
So if you take a look at the
slide that I've just put up,
what it is is an in-context flow
that we support both on
desktop and mobile web.
And some of the key benefits of
using this flow are that it
keeps customers on your
site while they're
completing their purchase.
So it increases conversion.
And it's a very simple
integration for integrators.
From a consumer perspective,
it provides convenience as
well as the security of the
Google Wallet brand to
complete their payments.
And the last key point of one
of the great things that we
are very proud of that we've
been able to do for
integrators is provide really
developer-friendly pricing.
So it's 5% for microtransactions
or 1.9 plus
30% US dollars for larger
transactions.
And the lowest price is
automatically applied.
MIHAI IONESCU: Great.
Can you give us some example?
Who are the users of this API?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Absolutely.
So we've been fortunate to
partner with some great
developers.
And up on this slide, you'll
see just a few of the great
developers we've been working
with over the past year plus--
Zynga, Kabam, Graphicly,
Playdom, Rovio.
MIHAI IONESCU: Wow.
That looks like all big names.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Absolutely.
MIHAI IONESCU: And are we also
using this at Google?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Yes,
we absolutely are.
So the other key point about
Google Wallet for Digital
Goods is that in addition to
powering a number of great
external developers, Google
Wallet is the way to pay
across Google.
So for any user who's completing
a transaction on
Google Play, Google Offers,
Google+, Google Voice, they're
all paying with stored
credentials from Google Wallet.
And the great part about that is
that's really enabled us to
scale up our Wallet user base
tremendously, which is
obviously an advantage to
developers looking to
integrate because it makes sure
that a greater percentage
of your user base will be able
to get a single-click purchase
experience.
MIHAI IONESCU: Sounds like an
easy to use and easy to
implement API.
Do you have an example?
Can we see a demo
how it works?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Absolutely.
So one of the integrators I've
mentioned on the previous
slide was Graphicly.
They do digital content
distributions.
Comic books are just one example
of what they sell.
And I am now logged
into Graphicly
with my Google account.
If I choose to purchase The
Walking Dead, I'm able to do
so very quickly from
their page.
Here's the Buy Now button.
By clicking that, it will now
invoke the Google Wallet for
Digital Goods API, which
should be loading.
As you can see, the purchase
screen loads up
right over the content.
So there's no redirect away.
And you can also see that
because, again, as a user who
also purchases from Google
Play or Offers, my stored
credentials are available
right here, both
cards that is use.
MIHAI IONESCU: So you choose
whatever card you want.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: So I can
choose very quickly.
And then very quickly complete
a purchase with
just a single click.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Very nice.
It's nice that we gloss over the
window, and you can still
see what you're purchasing.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Right.
MIHAI IONESCU: And it's good for
the website that the user
does not actually
leave the site.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Leave
the sites.
MIHAI IONESCU: It's not taking
to another page.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: It's much
less jarring for them.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: And we do see
improved conversion from that.
So one thing I'll point out just
before I talk a little
bit more about how this is
performed for Graphicly, is
that this confirmation screen
is optional for integrators.
So it's up to them whether
they'd like to show it as an
additional confirmation.
Or you can turn it off,
and then it is
literally just one screen.
But to your point of the fact
that it's in context,
Graphicly has seen, overall, 5%
increase in conversion from
implementing this flow, and
also 10 to 22% increase in
revenue per item depending on
the item, partially due to the
friendliness of the
pricing scheme.
MIHAI IONESCU: That's
very nice.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Yeah.
So let me--
MIHAI IONESCU: So besides
Graphicly, and we've seen a
lot of big names on the previous
slide, big game
companies, are there other
use cases for this API?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Absolutely.
One of things we tend to see
with digital content is games
are often early integrators.
But there are a wide variety
of use cases that can be
served with this type of
integration, so online
services, anything from
something like TaskRabbit to
match.com that you can
pay for online--
online apps and software;
games, as I've already
mentioned; paid content, so
music, videos, articles that
you pay for.
Event tickets and non-profits
are all segments that we're
starting to work with
more broadly and are
very excited about.
MIHAI IONESCU: I see this slide
is covering basically
the entire spectrum of digital
goods and services.
What is the average
transaction size?
Do we have any numbers
around that?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: So that's
actually one of the great and
very interesting things as we
look at who's integrating and
who our user base is.
Given the very flexible pricing
structure, we have
integrators whose typical
transaction price is $0.99 all
the way up to integrators whose
typical transaction is
hundreds of dollars.
And again, it tends to vary
a little bit by industry.
So when you're talking about
apps or online services, you
see higher ticket prices
versus games.
But the pricing structure
as well as the overall
architecture support both.
PENG YING: Cool.
One of the questions that we
hear a lot is when will Google
Wallet for Digital Goods be
available in my country?
Can you speak about
internationalization at all
and where it's currently
available?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Absolutely.
So to start with, it's
something that is a
priority for us.
Since launching, we've
opened up support to
over 18 seller countries.
Now, one thing to point out is
that, in general, all of
Google Wallet products are
available online to buyers in
140 countries.
But you can set up
as a seller.
We support 18 countries
and 9 currencies.
The process to get additional
countries added involves
making sure that we can
support that all
throughout our stack.
It's something we continually
work to do.
And we are looking to add
additional countries in the
next couple months.
MIHAI IONESCU: Very
nice slide.
I like the summary here
with the nice, simple
graphic right there.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: With
all the flags.
MIHAI IONESCU: With all
the flags, yes.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Absolutely.
PENG YING: So I don't know if
you can get into any more
detail about that.
Like a lot of developers are
always asking, oh, why isn't
this available in Poland?
Or why isn't this available
in the Czech Republic?
Or those countries.
And I'm guessing there's a lot
of procedurals and regulations
that would have to comply
to before it can
be available there.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Yeah,
absolutely.
And as I mentioned, it is the
very top priority for us to
work through each of those so
that we can bring this support
to more and more developers.
We are looking at launching four
additional countries in
the next month or two.
So stay tuned for
more details.
That's about as much as I can
say today about that.
But you are right.
We do have to evaluate on a
country-by-country basis what
is the licensing and the
regulatory position and make
sure that we're perfectly
set up.
PENG YING: OK.
So let's get into one of the new
features-- subscriptions.
Can you tell us a little
bit about that?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Absolutely.
So we're very excited
about subscriptions.
We announced them at I/O.
And they are live
in production now.
We have support for
monthly billing.
And in addition to that, you
can support free trials are
prorated first month.
One of the things I wanted to
mention is while we announced
subscriptions for external
developers at Google I/O, this
is the same subscriptions
platform that powers
subscriptions at Google,
whether you're buying a
subscription through Google or
YouTube for premium content or
even Google Storage, as
I've illustrated here,
Google Drive Storage.
So in addition to being able to
support monthly billing and
these particular use cases,
integrators who integrate with
us will then be able to have
buyers manage their
subscriptions via the Google
Subscription management UIs.
We also provide merchant
tools for that.
And just one area of
subscriptions that I did want
to call out is we do have
support for dunning
management.
PENG YING: What is dunning?
[LAUGHTER]
ARUNDHATI SINGH: So it's a
subscriptions-related term.
But what it really means is
that when you've created a
relationship with your customer
and they've agreed
that they want your service
on an ongoing basis, but
something goes wrong-- their
credit card gets declined in a
few months--
we help you manage that process
so you don't lose that
subscriber.
So the way that works in this
launch is that there is a
grace period.
We notify the subscriber.
We provide them a way for them
to update their payment
information and RUIs.
And that'll apply to all future
subscription periods.
MIHAI IONESCU: Got it.
PENG YING: Cool.
MIHAI IONESCU: Very exciting.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Absolutely.
We're very excited about
subscriptions.
PENG YING: Where do you see the
future of Google Wallet
for Digital Goods going?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: So as
always, it's hard to
speak to specific roadmaps.
But there are a few things that
are on our mind overall
as a product that we can talk
to you about today.
And I've listed just a few of
them here on the slide.
So user challenges is one
for risk-based reasons.
Basically, the ability to say,
re-enter your password to
complete this purchase or
provide the last four digits
of your credit card.
We are also, as mentioned
earlier, looking at supporting
additional merchant countries
in the very near future.
As mentioned, subscriptions is
something that we've launched
very recently at Google I/O. And
we'd like to continue to
extend and enhance
that offering.
And one of the things that I
can say about that is we
absolutely are looking at
providing support for
additional subscription
billing periods.
A couple other tools to make--
so that's more in the core
product and in the
buyer experience.
We're also looking at how can
we make it easier for
merchants and developers
to then manage
their day-to-day business.
So we will be rolling out a
brand new merchant center with
improved UI and enhanced
functionality, including
support for better subscription
management.
And also analytics to help you
better realize how your
business is performing.
PENG YING: So you were talking
about user challenges before.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Absolutely.
PENG YING: And then I'm just
thinking about it.
I don't quite understand how
that would simplify the flow.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Right.
PENG YING: What the
benefit of it is.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: I'm glad you
asked that question because
it's an important one
to understand.
The reason that user challenges
are an important
part of the experience is that
they enable us to complete a
higher percentage of
transactions that might
otherwise be flagged as risk
or friendly fraud.
This is an issue we see
with digital goods.
Now, a lot of things we've
done have enabled us to
streamline the purchase flow,
enabling you to have a longer
session so that users aren't
constantly prompted for login
before completing
the purchase.
But a key component of that is
that to make sure that it's
not someone from your family
making an unauthorized
purchase on your behalf or that
your account hasn't been
taken over.
These challenges are a really
low-friction way to make sure
that we can continue to enable
that more seamless experience
in the very broad majority
of cases.
PENG YING: Got it.
So we're trying to reduce the
friendly fraud and like--
ARUNDHATI SINGH: We're trying
to reduce friendly fraud.
And again, make sure that
a higher percentage of a
merchant's transactions go
through as opposed to being
flagged by risk and failing.
MIHAI IONESCU: Protect
both the merchant--
ARUNDHATI SINGH: And
the consumer.
MIHAI IONESCU: And
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Absolutely.
PENG YING: Cool.
And I think that's pretty
much all the
questions that we have.
We didn't get to interrogate
you there.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: No.
I love talking about this
product, super excited about
it, and happy to answer any
questions that developers or
prospective developers
may have about it.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
Let's look at online
questions.
We actually got a few.
PENG YING: So if somebody wanted
to integrate this,
where would they go for
information or resources?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Sure.
PENG YING: What's the URL?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: So if you go
to wallet.google.com, you'll
find information about all
of our online products.
And this particular product, as
mentioned, is Google Wallet
for Digital Goods.
PENG YING: Got it.
MIHAI IONESCU: Thank you.
All right.
Time for online submitted
questions.
I'm looking at our Moderator
page right now.
And of course, we have a
question about launching in
more countries and currencies.
And the country mentioned is
Poland, which we actually
picked as an example.
PENG YING: Psychic.
[LAUGHTER]
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: I will say that
we know that there's a
very active developer
base in Poland.
And it is very close to the
top of the priority list.
And so hopefully, you'll hear
something exciting in the next
month or two.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
Have a-- you want to
do the next one?
PENG YING: Yeah, I'll
do the next one.
So Stephen from New York asks,
"Can I use the Digital Goods
Wallet API to support
my blog?"
ARUNDHATI SINGH: You absolutely
can use this API to
support a blog.
Just like you would do for a
normal e-commerce integration,
you can sign up for a merchant
account, again, at
wallet.google.com.
Once you've signed up for a
merchant account, you are
absolutely free to use this
API to integrate with your
blog and ask for support.
PENG YING: Are there any caveats
with support versus
donation versus contribution?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: So, a great
thing to clarify.
In some of our additional
products, we do make a
distinction between donations
and political contributions.
So we provide Donate buttons.
But to use those,
you have to be a
registered 5013(c) nonprofit.
And similarly with our
Contribute buttons, you have
to be a registered federal
political candidate or a
political action committee.
But to be able to just use this
API and to be set up as a
merchant, you can use that
for a support use case.
You just won't be entitled
to use the Donate
or Contribute buttons.
PENG YING: Got it.
MIHAI IONESCU: Let's move
on to the next question.
This one is from James
who's testing
subscription in the sandbox.
And he wants to know "As the
user places the order, how can
he cancel the subscription right
away?" He's trying to
test the entire API.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: So users are
actually able to cancel
subscriptions by going
into their personal
Wallet accounts online.
So if I've made a purchase on
your site or if I've made a
purchase on Google Play, I can
then log into my account at
wallet.google.com.
And I'll see all of my
subscriptions listed there.
There's a subscription-specific
view.
And I can cancel from there.
MIHAI IONESCU: And you
can click and cancel?
ARUNDHATI SINGH: I can
click and cancel.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
And then I--
for the API, then James
will get a callback.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Yes.
So from a merchant
perspective--
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
From his perspective he wants
to know when that happens.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: How
he can test that.
MIHAI IONESCU: How
ARUNDHATI SINGH: So the minute
that a user cancels, we do
fire off a post back to the
merchant informing them so
that they can update their
subscriber databases.
And make sure to update that
particular user's account on
their site.
MIHAI IONESCU: I think
we have one more.
You wanna take it?
PENG YING: We do?
I have not seen it.
Oh, maybe we do.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK, just--
[LAUGHTER]
PENG YING: Why don't
you take this one?
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
People are submitting
it to live, so yes.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Great.
MIHAI IONESCU: So I have a
question coming from Canada.
"How will Google Wallet stay
competitive with devices ISIS
in US and worldwide?"
ARUNDHATI SINGH: OK, so this
particular product is actually
aimed at the Digital Goods
Market, Google Wallet for
Digital Goods.
So again, online services,
online apps and software,
tickets and events, games.
So it's not directly competitive
to ISIS or Square.
PENG YING: OK.
And I guess if the question's
related to the physical wallet
or the tap-and-pay wallet,
then none of
us our subject experts.
And we will bring on somebody
from Wallet again to answer
that later on.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: And I believe
there was a recent session
done with Robin Dua that's
probably available online to
go back and look at.
PENG YING: Yeah.
So you can probably check out
last week's Wallet session.
I think we covered something
similar to that when we were
talking about ISIS and MCX and
other initiatives as well.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Right.
But just to be clear again,
for this product it's not
directly competitive
to either.
And we are seeing very good
traction in the market with
it, which we're excited about.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cool.
Looks like we keep receiving
questions live as we speak.
[LAUGHTER]
MIHAI IONESCU: Let me look
at the next one.
So the next one has to do with
subscription periods.
And in particular, it looks
like three months and six
months are quite popular.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Right.
So as I mentioned, right now
we support monthly billing.
But we are absolutely looking
for feedback from our
developers of what additional
periods are most important
because this is something we'd
like to continue to enhance.
So please do send that feedback
through our Developer
Relations team or
on our forums.
Whether weekly, biweekly,
quarterly, six months, or
annual, what are your
priorities?
And we can look to
incorporate that.
PENG YING: Are you doing
anything like
merchant-initiated
recurrences?
So I would say I want a
bill something like
12 times in a year.
But then I can bill at any
period or at any rate as long
as I submit an API request.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: So at this
point, we will do the
initiation of the charges on
behalf of the merchant.
And it will be based on an
ongoing subscription schedule
that's established upfront
with the user.
PENG YING: Got it.
But--
OK.
Cool.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: But again,
that's what we're really
looking for in terms of feedback
from developers via
our forums what are the use
cases you'd like to see us
enhance so we can
help prioritize.
PENG YING: Sounds good
MIHAI IONESCU: Keep getting
more questions about
international availability.
[LAUGHTER]
ARUNDHATI SINGH: We answered
that one to death.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Absolutely.
MIHAI IONESCU: Things--
more countries are coming.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: It's absolutely
a priority for us.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
So I think this is it.
We're getting closer to
our allocated time.
So thanks everyone for
watching again.
And thanks, Arundhati,
for stopping by.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Thank you.
Very happy to be here.
MIHAI IONESCU: And we'll
see you next time.
Bye.
ARUNDHATI SINGH: Take care.
PENG YING: That's it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]